if you are playing CS2 and you are not
abusing shotguns you are trolling I was
playing an inferno pugy the day and I
got absolutely Fried by this guy running
a shoty on
short wow wow and so I was just like you
know what I'm going to buy this thing
and see how insane it actually
is it's an OP it's an OP it's so
stupid Oh my God this gun is so broken
let's go we're heating
up yeah one tap the spraying and the hit
RG Feels So Bad on the actual rifles and
SMGs that I think people have just
started buying shotguns because you just
you can't miss Let's test
that
brother oh my God and it's just so dumb
look at this it's just so
stupid it's just that easy